je voulais vous poser la question que
peut faire un ministre de l'intérieur
pour que la sécurité 16 est un sujet
pour les français ils étaient plus de
150 à venir poser leurs questions lors
de la vingt septième réunion publique de
sartrouville en présence de gérald
darmanin ministre de l'intérieur et de
la députée des yvelines il ya elles
broutent peavey sujet phare de départ la
sécurité
c'est un des thèmes qui se dégage dans
la campagne électorale à venir même si
c'est pas le premier centre d'intérêt
des français même si c'est pas le seul
thème ça fait partie de ces thèmes et
c'est le cadre d'interventions du
ministre de l'intérieur délinquance chez
les jeunes drogue forces de l'ordre
immigration ou encore vaccination les
thématiques abordées étaient multiples
répondre directement aux questionnements
et inquiétudes des citoyens un format
participatif qui permet une proximité
entre élus et population locale suis élu
municipal à montesson et que je trouve
que c'est fantastique d'organiser des
réunions où il ya de l'échangé de la
proximité donc je suis ravi d'avoir
d'avoir été là et puis j'ai appris des
choses et je fais ça très bien quand
vous faites de la politique vous
représenter les citoyens il vous donne
un mandat pour agir en leur nom et donc
la moindre des choses c'est de venir
régulièrement devant eux pour leur
parler et pour avoir cet échange très
intéressés et gym intéressés par notre
ministre à l'intérieur je voulais voir
ce qu'il en était
au niveau du filet je voulais voir si
avis et si allez avoir beaucoup de monde
l'occasion pour le ministre de revenir
sur les mesures phares du quinquennat
d'emmanuel macron à cinq mois de
l'élection présidentielle
2h30 des changes des réunions qui
devrait se poursuivre encore dans le
futur avec de nouveaux invités